la familia de george florida y el equipo
legales que estuvo hoy en la casa blanca
ha reunido con el presidente job ayer le
pidió tanto a demócratas como
republicanos que pasen la ley
georg floyd para reformar la policía a
nivel nacional una ley que el presidente
yo bailén le había pedido al congreso
que aprobara para hoy 25 de mayo cuando
se cumple un año del asesinato de georg
floyd pero que el senado no ha podido
pasar todavía aunque ya tiene el visto
bueno por parte de la cámara de
representantes la reforma policial pide
entre otras cosas prohibir los
estrangulamientos parar los
allanamientos no autorizados y acabar
con la inmunidad calificada para los
oficiales de la policía acusados de
crímenes al respecto
filoni sea floyd el hermano de la
víctima dijo que eeuu se puede hacer
leyes para proteger al pájaro que es
símbolo de la nación y que si ese es el
caso también se pueden hacer leyes para
proteger a la gente de color tras su
visita a la casa blanca la familia de
floyd
también se reunió con la presidenta del
congreso nancy pelosi entre otros
congresistas
hay que mencionar que varios periodistas
reportaron en minneapolis en la plaza
específicamente de georges lloyd en esa
ciudad disparos horas antes de los
eventos de conmemoración